babe got a brand new hour of stand-up
material April 12th in Austin at the
Paramount Theater is sold out the only
tickets we have left are April 13th at
the Empire Theater in San Antonio Texas
May 5th Buffalo first show sold out
second Show tickets May 6 Ithaca has
tickets May 7th Albany all sold out May
28th Newport Rhode Island the second
show has some tickets left and then
September 22nd in New York Radio City
sold out September 23rd theater at
Madison Square Garden we have tickets my
big New York City shows I will not be in
the New York area other than those two
shows and Sydney Australia June 9th it
remains to be seen but buy tickets I'll
give you a full refund if I don't show
up christycomedy.com for tikiwickies
guys I want to tour with the Jokers
right now speaking of new episodes every
Thursday night at 10 on TBS and True TV
and then we're going to Bangor Maine uh
three at the Wang April 28th and 29th in
Boston we got the Maverick Center in
Utah on May 5th the Bellco Theater in
Denver on May 6th then we're going to
Arlington uh we're going to Austin Texas
The Moody Center Sugar Land uh that's
May 19th 20th and 21st we're gonna keep
going going to Columbus we're going to
Cleveland going to Detroit Minneapolis
Des Moines Kansas City Nashville
Indianapolis St Louis it's all up there
we're also adding dates so if you don't
see your dates you just go back and
check we're adding it's
impracticaljokerslive.com for all the
tickets I love you God bless you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
you think I'm in love
[Music]
but that innocent hey babe hey babe hey
baby baby oh let me tell you something
right now I want to tell you something
yeah I went to Florida this past uh two
weekends ago yeah I ate too much I
stayed too long in the Sun and I I I I I
feel bloated and I'm burnt prove me
wrong
well I'll tell you right now you don't
look bloated and you don't look burnt so
that's two right there you don't think I
look burnt right now I see no burn on
you at all really not not at all I see a
light bronze I feel burnt I was in
here's what happened I went we had shows
SPF SPF no we didn't here's what
happened I had a show in Miami uh
there's Fountain Blue in Miami yeah and
and I should have realized that I go I
Jazz was with me and I say I don't have
any sunblock we're already down at the
beach he goes I'll go to the room and
get it in the 20 minutes it took her to
go to the room get it bring it back I
burnt to a crisp bro how about this
about
let's call it
15 years ago I got sun poisoning for the
one of the two times in my life at the
Fontainebleau in Miami sun poisoning I
went there for uh uh some you know this
is a website called thrillist
through this like big weekend for like
people in the industry
I got invited I went down there overcast
all weekend I was in the pool no shirt
on overcast
this set by the end of the first day I I
was so sick I got a full-blown fever I
was completely dehydrated my skin was
blistering I couldn't sleep I couldn't
lay my body down to sleep I had to sleep
no shirt the aloe all that pain the
lidocaine and I I put pillows behind my
lower back and slept oh right like this
like the [__] grandmother on the roof
of the other of the station wagon and
vacation you probably don't know that
reference no but I'm I'm here for it
yeah I in Phantom blue
Fountain Blue
I played Phantom blue oh is it a
nightclub anymore no Liv we want to live
after but there was a they they set up a
big conference room they set up a
thousand seats in a conference room so
who who got you there Phantom blue or
someone else what do you mean there's no
Club there no no through my agent this
is like I did it Sam who was your Booker
like what is it
oh oh so so they have a Comedy Room
exactly exactly okay well I don't know
if it's a comedy room they just do
comedy shows there once in a while it's
right across the street from live right
across the alley from live in the big in
the big old yeah you choose to perform
perform there on that stage wow it was
like a music venue so what is the setup
it's just just just rows of seeds
straight back rows of seats which is not
optimal for for comedy yeah people that
go there like to get down did you have
Rowdy drunks oh yeah Rowdy drunks we had
a good time
but sun poisoning a friend of mine who
was down there at the front on blue with
me got sun poisoning and they said they
were shaking on the floor the next
morning uncontrollable shaking felt like
death fever nauseous whatever had to get
on a flight but they said they literally
were contemplating going to the
emergency room it was more than just the
pain in the skin it was a like a
systemic fever so what are the signs and
symptoms of poisoning this is exactly
headache fever chills nausea dizziness
dehydration swelling pain tickling
tingling skin redness and blistering
that's every one of those do you ever
hear the commercial on on the radio it's
like like can you scroll up a second
it's like you know it's like headache
fever chills nausea Diaries
someone got hired that can sing and just
went into the booth and was like take
two and she's like
dude my daughter you know is she's she's
you know a year and like 10 months now
so she'll tell us like diaper or like
she'll like she'll just sit down in a
corner and like Squat and like like that
yesterday I got home from from Florida
literally explosion no I walk in she lit
because she's talking now she goes like
little words she I don't know she must
have heard on the TV whatever I walk in
I'm home for maybe 45 seconds she goes
Dada I got a [__]
did you lose it I lost it we lost it we
wish we were filming it because I guess
somebody said I got a certain sheep but
she said dad and we were dying we told
her not to say it but now she says [__]
oh that's great but it was funny how she
was like Dad I got a [__] it was amazing
shout out my daughter wow
if you're listening yeah yeah
um so okay so you had a whole jaunt in
Florida yeah you drove
flew to we did West Palm Beach the Palm
Beach Improv for three shows then we had
a day off and one night three shows what
no one show Tuesday two Wednesday off
Thursday to see the Mets Marlins opening
day
at the park there though that was
awesome Friday Fountain Blue hook that
up Cohen's the cohens shout out Friday
Fountain Blue Saturday Tampa Theater
which is amazing run great Tampa theater
is the best my dad found a parking spot
did you go to Bern's Steakhouse no I
forgot about it and all when I look
because I don't run my social medias
that when I looked at my Twitter my guy
was like Hey everyone's keep telling you
to go to burn Steakhouse but he told me
at like 11 o'clock at night and I was
like I [__] forgot yeah I forgot
about Burns to be honest has your dad
been there he had not okay to be honest
with you
TBH I wouldn't have had time it's a four
and a half hour drive from Miami to
Tampa and I didn't realize that okay so
I would have by the time we got we had
to drop how about this you were with the
crew with the whole yeah me uh Tommy the
tour manager the the great Mike Cannon
was with me
um and Jasmine how about this she you
know we're at the pool Cabana on
Thursday hanging out before the Mets
game wait for it
they hooked it up no no get mad they
gave me one bottle at live and one
bottle at the Cabana but of course the
you know I was with my boys from home
there was a lot of money to be spent I
just gave my check for my Miami to the
Fountain pretty much I got [__] so I I
um sweet sweet yeah nice so Jasmine she
she we're all at the Cabana getting
drunk right whatever I'm having fun I
was holding because you know girls like
to go out I don't know what it is they
like to go out with no purses and
nothing and they just go out with an ID
and a credit card and I'm like did she
even have a clutch it's not safe nothing
I no she had nothing she goes that's it
and then she tells me to hold her
license and credit card so I hold it
she's like drunk I have to go up to
start to like rest and like I had a call
or whatever this was Friday where I
actually had a show at at um at I had a
show that night I wasn't off so I and
then she goes give me my credit card and
ID and I was like well no because you're
gonna lose it she's like how am I
supposed to [__] order anything if I
don't have a credit card an ID I'm like
why don't you just do what all everyone
else is doing and just binge off me why
don't you just
do what what everyone else in this
Cabana you had the older yeah all those
people why don't you just freeload like
they all are you had everybody down
there everybody you gotta fly
they all flew down yeah they all flew
down so it was nice it was nice did you
were able to walk around the ground so
now everybody bothering you uh
some people some people were yeah well
it was funny too because and then I'll
get back to it but Tampa and my show in
Tampa Theater I did had no idea the
Tampa Bay Lightning were playing at home
at 7 p.m the day was having a show
against the New York Islanders so all
these Islanders fans were coming out of
my show but I couldn't see you go to the
game and I was like
what they're like why would you have I
could have probably sold another
thousand tickets because those people
just if I would have done Tampa Friday
right instead of Saturday I would
because all those people everybody kept
saying the same thing to me I've been
here all weekend I I already got tickets
to the game yeah
we had nothing to do last night well I'm
in Miami getting sunburned yeah so jazz
is on [__] give me the keys so give
me the give me the license so I give it
to him
all of us and in the hotel room key I'm
taking a nap I I wake up I have five
missed calls from Jasmine I don't know I
call her back she's like where the [__]
are you I was like I'm in the room I
fell asleep she's like I've been
knocking and I was like why don't you
just use the room key she's like hello I
lost it that's what she says
so she comes in look like you're
supposed to know yeah she's like hello
what did you think was gonna happen of
course I was gonna so she loses that the
license the room
we have the head of Fountain Blue
security who's got other better things
to do yeah looking searching the Cabana
searching every step he said he said he
potentially searched 10 000 steps worth
of backtracking that guy was literally
he gave you that stat that's what he
said to us like a guy that's a buttoned
up he goes it was at ten thousand steps
of of searching
okay drunk whatever I'm actually angry
because I'm like this is a problem now
we got because now she's per served at
least perturbed I'm stressed from the
show she's flying home the next day from
Miami to back to New York I have to
drive to Tampa So the plan was to drop
off at the airport hang out all night
drop off at the airport say about 12 for
flights at two and then go on our way
now we have to wake up two hours earlier
to get her to the airport earlier
because she has no idea you've got to
get to the airport four hours early now
because we have to put you through a
rigorous a rigorous
uh ID and I didn't even know you could
do that so you can fly without ID that
you have to have another credit card
with your name on it you have to have
like a picture of your ID somewhere on
your phone and then they ask you crazy
questions of what was your mother's
birthday and like things like that like
things that only the government would
know right so so we're going we're all
up like angrily getting even even my
tour manager was like I can't believe we
have to [__] wake up at 7am to do
this I was like well you get paid to
just shut your mouth right okay
you put in the ten thousand steps yeah
yeah no I'm kidding he's a great guy and
uh and and and and and and and
um and so great hair by the way my tour
managers when I see him I'll judge it
I'll put his hair up against anybody's
[__] hair really on unbelievable hair
unbelievable hair in the fact makes
vanitya look bald really yeah Infinity
has great hair do you mean that he has
hair that always sits the right way is
that what you mean no he he is a is he's
a white man with a curly Afro that that
is his hair is absolutely perfect cool
guy smoke cigars in the pool at great I
would have a Bob Ross if I could my
whole life he's Bob he's my Bob Ross
okay
he so he yeah so we're all up you know
Jasmine's like I'm so sorry because now
she's oh woke up the next day like what
happened last night I'm okay you're like
hello yeah so now we're up because you
let's go whatever
so she's going she's getting dressed
she's putting on her shoes she she
starts laughing it's in a pocket I mean
it's in her shoes her license ID and
credit card were in her shoes she goes I
completely forgot I put it in my [__]
did she walk up holding the shoes is
that what it was she walked up she
walked up barefooting so she had him in
her hand she walked with them yes she
was knocking when they were on her purse
yes yeah then we go to the Soho house we
go to the Soho house uh because we were
operating so we said you know what let's
go to the breakfast place Tommy go back
to bed we can wait a little bit go saw
house we have a full breakfast Jazz has
her she goes I have my license it is
right here what like I was like do not
lose it whatever she goes to someone
house she goes guys I feel terrible I
feel terrible about this tells me and my
Cannon were with her Chris even paying
for everything do not pay for this I got
this okay fine
lost a credit card on the walk from
Fountain Blue to the saw house kept her
license lost the credit card so Nan I
was like What He just go on the plane
get on the plane get out of here wow
yeah wow that's what happened she got
the to she she [__] up she done [__]
up on that the only thing that she found
that weekend was love in a hopeless
place right
much like a girl Rihanna yeah you you
were you were you were you in this kind
of fit out there no were you calling
like because this is this is flashy this
is Flash you look like a prize fighter
right and and I don't feel like one I do
feel bloated and sunburned but I do
appreciate look by the way look at the
difference why right but that's always
going to happen right I got a bit of
this one
wow you're [__] you're you're peeling
right you went to Tex-Mex yeah
um I wasn't in a fit like this I did
what I did in Miami you know what I did
is I had on just a black T-shirt black
jeans chain out I was wearing the chain
out which was also black so I was
getting a couple of compliments on oh
that's a good Miami fit which is
interesting because I didn't think it
was that's what you did for stage that's
what I did for saying what about the
pool what did you do for the pool uh
colorful board shorts I went white trash
just uh basketball shorts I went your
white trash if you put on a pair of
non-bathing suit shorts as your bathing
suit which is what I did you went in the
pool in basketball shorts basketball
shorts you have a you have bathing suits
forgot them all I pulled the Jasmine you
packed for Miami for Florida without a
baby no bathing suit shorts no
flip-flops what'd you have I wore one
time you walked around like high tops I
wore my Air Max 270s with no socks okay
okay but you couldn't go into like the
the Phantom blue uh like uh store and
buy yourself
I'd already blown all my money on uh low
for the Sunburn and you went in you went
in with the basketball shorts I went in
with the basketball shorts because she
was soaked well soaked and she was like
I can see your dick print [__]
that's why you wear a bathing suit I was
like well what bathing suit that
happened
they're gonna they're gonna have to
they're gonna have to deal with it okay
but so you were walking around dick
print out and you knew it and you didn't
care print was out having fun right
um and it was a great weekend uh great
weekend with jazz my friends Mike the
Great Mike Cannon uh nimesh Patel was on
the shows with me in West Palm Beach
who's fantastic and um and Mike and Mike
well Mike was on Tampa and Miami nimesh
was on West Palm because the mesh worked
with me at West Palm Beach on Tuesday
and Wednesday because he was headlining
the club on his own Friday Saturday
Sunday so he was just down there a
couple of days early he was like well if
you don't have an opener he's like I'll
just I'll do it like I'll just like you
know I'll do 20 minutes oh awesome so it
was great so and I had a Florida weekend
I've in the past two weeks done Orlando
Jacksonville Fort Myers Miami Tampa and
West Palm I'm very I'm flying you're
retired I'm Riff Raff yeah you are
refreshed I would like to see you in
refresh uh hair
no yes he does really yes he's the only
guy I gotta see it yeah okay so you had
an eventful weekend I went to brunch on
Saturday
okay I walked around outside because it
all of a sudden supposed to rain was 73
and sunny in Nuevo York in Nueva York so
you had it
had an A in Nueva York could you almost
never happened I got a haircut I was in
the burg looks good by the way I did a
walker me in Casey went to brunch Casey
Jones with our gals and everything and
then uh walked around ran into people
that I knew in the street I ran into q
and my buddy Eric at a place day
drinking you just randomly ran into
walked into them we were like what the f
and then we all we all became a super
unit like Voltron wait where were you
guys where did you run into kill in
Brooklyn or Manhattan uh in Brooklyn he
was there because my friend Eric lives
there and he was visiting them and so we
just so we hope it was the whole thing
then I went home had people over
WrestleMania uh wrestling is too nice
two nine Affair now and uh now that they
care but it was amazing and it was
amazing WrestleMania This is one
WrestleMania
um for the main event I mean look there
were like 10 12 big big matches but I
guess you could say the second eye main
event was Roman Reigns versus Cody
Rhodes and do you know either of those
people I know Roman Reigns
no uh stop right now if it's a spoiler
Roman Reigns won okay why don't you be a
spoiler you got to watch I mean how have
they not seen WrestleMania it's two
weeks later oh yeah yeah so I mean yeah
yeah you're not a real fan no you're not
uh no one thought he was going to so
it's a little bit controversial okay
anyway but this and that so yeah and
then Snoop Dogg was in WrestleMania dude
how about this one so so so missing the
face yeah so so The Miz right so so The
Miz is the host and he's hosting with
Snoop right and then you know who Shane
McMahon is it's Instagram's son he's
never around he comes back like just for
Wrestlemania and nobody knew he was
coming and he comes out to fight The Miz
on a like just on the Fly dude it was
insane right so Snoop calls the fight
they ring the bell it's just out of
nowhere like it's just [__] around
it's like more of a comedic thing and uh
Shane throws Miss against the ropes and
then jumps over him you know like how
they do when they lands down literally
busts his knee rips his quad right there
in the first five seconds like all live
he comes out no one's seen him in a year
or two the place goes batshit crazy he's
like I'm gonna fight you miss ding ding
ding he throws he jumps falls down his
leg pops he just goes down he's just
rolling around on the ground you see it
happen and then they won't show like
they'll just show The Miz after that
because they won't show the injury they
won't show what's going on which
happened three times last night which
never happens in three different matches
people got hurt
he popped his knee and then no one knew
what to do and then Snoop just gets on
the mic he gets to the ring he's like
are you okay on the mic he was he okay
he's like is everything all right he's
like it's
he's really injured so he's supposed to
keep baby he's supposed to like you know
so he's what does kfabe it means Kate
babe means we will all agree that this
is re everything's real you know like
that wrestling what's going on in the
universe or the wrestling of the of the
storyline is we believe it right it's so
if he's really hurt he was supposed to
be hurt no no he was he's so K faves out
the window because he really injured
himself okay so yes when you break it's
like you break character okay what is
the protocol okay by the way K babe and
hey babe it's okay babe oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah so so so everyone's like what
what's gonna happen Snoop you know
you're not supposed to even call
attention to the guy on the floor who's
the owner of the company basically and
he goes are you all right
and then he turns away he goes nah and
he just punches Miss in the face so miss
goes like a real punch he thinks it
wasn't real it was like you know but he
punches me in the face and then then
Snoop just goes I'll fight you and then
he he Snoop goes against the ropes and
it's not really conditioned as a
wrestler he's tall he's lanky he's like
60 and he goes against her if he hops
over it was so [__] funny he drops a
people's elbow on him and then uh he
wins the match and the place went nuts
it was probably funnier than and better
than it would have been if if you
genuinely think Snoop Dogg genuinely
improv the entire thing what I believe
what I believe is that there was
um a spot at the end of their match
where he was probably gonna do it anyway
and he just kind of did Fast Forward and
look what he does
like
he's literally doing the right he throws
his sunglasses out
man I kind of love Snoop Dogg he does he
does the entire that's right
amazing right yeah
the crowd went crazy yeah that's the
rock he did the whole entire thing it
was so goddamn funny but people are
saying that like they did the press
conference people are just like oh he's
a professional he just stepped up
right someone told him do the people's
elbow and he just did it but we can't
see the injury of is it gruesome oh
you'll see it is oh god there were so
many gruesome injuries this week in
wrestling really yeah if you look up
Dante Martin from Top Flight dude this
spot they were doing was there was a
there was a pyramid of tables three
tables okay two tables and then these
guys
um yeah okay this I always feel this
pain in my ass
are we gonna get flagged for this pimpy
maybe don't play audio is that okay
because I I feel like I feel like it
always kind of um
it always was uh like amazing to me how
they don't get hurt the most of any
athlete they they get hurt a lot a lot
like but not by then gruesomely gruesome
like like how when Owen Hart fell and
like like died yeah no but before that
he had a gruesome leg or ankle injury
yeah probably I don't let me say yeah
yeah at roh Superstar dude it's like
it's like uh who was a quarterback that
[__] Joe Theisman no recently
someone broke now is this it yeah you
could get there's a different angle from
above that you see the whole thing
happen they're on two tables he's doing
gonna Power Bomb him through two tables
and he kind of like
lunch in my opinion these are the best
athletes they are they are the best in
math I mean the
you can't his foot is the wrong way dude
look look at his foot yeah look at his
left foot like a [__] no no his left
no I know I know I know I know yeah yes
oh my god dude oh my God that's not good
yeah
so what happens in there do they just
cart him off like I didn't see it live
so I don't know oh this was actually a
Ring of Honor um this wasn't even a
televised I'm not sure if it was still
if it was it was like a they shouldn't
have been doing that big of a spot on on
a regular show like if you're gonna take
those kind of risks and stuff like that
you kind of save it for like
pay-per-views or big right big match
spots so he got injured and almost in
vain because it was for nothing no one's
really seeing this it was like that Mets
player Edwin Diaz but that but that's
different because that's the World
Baseball Classic that means a lot to the
people of like that island but he got
hurt after the game partying no uh not
after game partying he they were
celebrating the win why are all these
athletes getting hurt I know it's weird
I tell you what I believe people still
do backflips off the cage and like UFC
you know what I think a big part of it
is though I think like it's a lot of
like as much as we're advancing in our
athletes you know taking types of
protein and steroids and this and that
even though it's you know safe and it is
I think it damages a little bit on a
microscopic level or cartilage or
ligaments and then you have a higher
risk of injury it could be you know that
that's what I think Riff Raff book
Drake's home studio for 500 000. we can
do for two hours we can offer that here
at the hey babes yeah we can absolutely
right now I'll give you a half price
I'll give you half price two hours 250.
you got the wrong 100 grand for the day
there's water's in the fridge whatever
you want what about Shane McMahon put on
Shane McMahon's injury yeah it was it
was I mean I hope Shane and no Shane I
hope he gets better and everything like
that I I that sucked completely sucks
yeah but it was like oh my God because
it was immediate right I felt they're
saying it wasn't getting hurt hurt a
shoot or a work so what do we mean okay
so a work is is kfabe a work is fake and
a shoot is real okay so a shoot means it
happened in the moment and it's it's out
of the storyline and a work means it's
part of the storyline it was intended to
happen now you guys I know you had the
opportunity to be involved in
WrestleMania but did you actually guys
actually wrestle and would you want to
do that so the last WrestleMania I did I
was a correspondent with Pat McAfee okay
um and I would want to wrestle and um I
was supposed to wrestle recently in aew
and uh we need to go down to uh and
train with QT martial in Atlanta for
like 12 sessions in order to get into a
match yeah I can't do it I don't have
the time so they just gave us a spot and
I actually got sick could make it and
they went you would they got beat with a
bat if you did have the time you would
actually is that a bucket list dream I
would love to do it okay yeah I can't
hold a match like Logan but Logan Paul
came in and it's like
Logan Paul I heard is like even if he
wasn't Logan Paul and you know obviously
famous from his other things could be an
actual just regular wrestler
I wonder in the locker room like how
many people like hats off this guy's
bringing eyes to the sport and he's
wrestling in these big stage matches
that people you know you don't just give
that to someone if they can unless they
can handle it because it's the biggest
stage of all right yeah but then I don't
know if there's other wrestlers are like
this guy just like a comic like
like if someone or off Tick Tock or
television just takes like a comedy club
spot and takes you know I don't know
people have 15 minutes people people no
but I don't know people like you know
he's taking a place in WrestleMania
where the wrestlers and wrestling 20
years can't get it right but in the same
way he's bringing a lot of eyes a lot of
eyes I mean how many tickets is this oh
my God 80
000 at night two nights that's not
including to
tonight you say Monday
today's Monday tonight as well is is the
follow-up show oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
holy [__] yeah yeah no they they sell
they sell 200 000 tickets
so Shane McMahon coming out I mean it's
just funny can you go back to the
beginning pimp it's just funny to come
out all the way to the beginning to come
out the way he came out like this and if
you hear that like the Crowd Goes I
don't want to get flagged but I mean
like look him coming out now the way he
came out backwards like that to know
that he's gonna get hurt in 90 seconds
[Laughter]
do we see the injury or is it just the
intro you see it oh I don't know but
it's like everyone and he shocked
everyone because he hasn't been around
all these guys are absolutely jacked too
it's just just he's a big dude man yeah
he's a big dude just the intro you got
there pimpy yeah all right if I could
find the footage of him being oh here we
go that's him being walked out oh my God
but it's in the match it's not even like
it's it's it happens like in the match
so it's like you see it a minute before
he was fine
yeah do you think you even give a crap
though honestly he does he does yeah
sure I think he I think what what they
said was he tore his quadricep that's
not but it looked like his knee blah
like his his his he hit the ground and
this part of his leg went out that way
oh my God can we see that you can't see
it yeah you can see this podcast
sponsored by better help thank you to
the people I better help for sponsoring
the show Sal and I use it we've
benefited from therapy if you if you
benefit from therapy this is the place
for you you getting to know yourself can
be a lifelong process we're always
changing revolving we just talked about
this on the Pod yeah not to quote to
quote uh to quote Ozzy Osbourne yes but
uh but later Charles Bradley covered the
song changes I'm going through changes
that's what better help is is better
help helps you adjust to those changes
all you do is fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can switch
therapists at any time for no additional
charge it is all done from the comfort
of your own home or wherever you want to
do it it is on line therapy no reason to
actually go in to to a brick and mortar
we have it all done online it is
discreet it is only between you and the
therapist and it literally is the best I
want you to go discover your potential
with better help and you're going to get
a sweet discount right now all you got
to do is visit betterhelp.com hey babe
today to get 10 off the first month
that's better help
help.com hey babe they're waiting for
you listen Sal there's something
important that I want to talk to you
about yeah and that's pooping anxiety
self-controlled constipation and nervous
diarrhea I know you experienced them
which many experiences suffer throughout
their lives but they don't talk about it
but the end of the day Sal it's just
poop is it it's just poop and seeds
d-s-01 makes it easier to go okay it
makes it easier to go it is a daily
symbiotic I'll tell you right you're
talking to the right guy yeah I don't
use the restroom too number two yeah
outside of my home you can't well can't
do it I have I have anxiety I have
anxiety well this is going to help you
it supports Health regularity healthy
motility and ease of evacuation that's a
fun way okay so that's what it is and
literally they have uh our capsule it's
it's called the Via cap it just aids
with digestion and it's delivery of an
average of 100 of the probiotic that
starts to dose to your colon so
basically just you get all those
probiotics in there and it helps your
colon with just all the processes that
it needs to be helped with to get that
poop out safe that's evacuate 16 of our
24 streams are specifically geared
toward Digestive Health that's what you
need got you okay
dry stools yeah supports gut ease from
occasional gas astronomical discomfort
associated with increased intestinal
Transit time bloating who doesn't have
bloating wow what about four specific
probiotic strains that have been shown
to promote healthy skin and reinforce a
healthy gut skin access if you know
anything you know that gut health is the
most important that's where it comes
from the gut and this helps you with it
now right now you can start a new
healthy habit today all you have to do
is visit seed.com hey babe and use code
hey babe to redeem 25 off your first
month of seeds ds01 daily symbiotic
that's seed.com hey babe and use that
code hey babe go poop with no anxiety
injury I like to look at that what if
you had the same thing happen to you as
you walked out at Radio City or Madison
Square Garden oh my God yeah if that if
that happened if I well first of all if
I jumped if I had somebody try to run
across me and jump I deserve it
um but if that happened in a comedy show
if I like was walking out and just
twisted my name I think I would just
have to continue to do the show just
sitting down and and it happened to me
what happened so I had uh I had straight
up whooping cough right pertussis I had
it for six weeks I coughed all day long
for six weeks I tore ligaments in my
back and I got to a point where it was
so bad that if I sneezed or left I was
fully incapacitated like I was nervous
to talk to anyone or go anywhere because
if I left or sneezed I would fall to the
ground and I couldn't move it was like
oh I season yeah yeah
this is it this is the first 10 seconds
this is it it's literally the verse that
watches me
yeah and they tried to get up you see it
yeah and that that it was the second
time putting pressure on it that's when
it
and then now they like you know so
you'll see it's real if this real the
ref will do that like and the ref did do
that I don't know if she did but she
probably so what is Miz thinking right
now right now he's he's buying time his
thought process is just by he knows he's
he knows he's hurt you know he's already
saying character people say Ms and I
look alike
I get what they mean he is much better
tall built guys
and then and then Snoop Jen then Snoop
does what you saw before yeah it it was
it was tough to say I felt bad for him
man
but uh so so anyway I I got to the point
where I was in writing excruciating I
couldn't even film the television show I
was in Florida we were filming at
Universal Studios okay and it was my
sixth week I was bedridden in Florida
and the guy from um uh uh Matthew uh I
can't believe I'm gonna forget a blank
on his name right now Perry no he's the
kid from um the dude from he's an adult
now from what's the wand the magic wand
Harry Potter yes Daniel Radcliffe no the
other guy he's hot
he's English he was a nerd but he grew
into his own he's a friend I can't
literally I'm so sorry he's like a buddy
of mine I forget his name Matthew
um this guy Matthew no no Harry Potter
hottie put in Harry Potter hottie I
can't believe Matthew uh it's at the tip
of my tongue
oh God Emma Watson
he's the main character
Nathaniel Radcliffe and that keeps going
right there no next one no Matthew
Matthew Draco
yeah that's it Matthew Lewis pull him up
I want to see him
sorry man Matthew you'll spend a minute
since I accessed your name in my brain
let's see oh yeah gorgeous there he is
so Matthew Lewis he took my place he was
friends with him he was visiting he was
on set I couldn't get out of bed he he
they did a thing of Jurassic Rod at the
park on the Rye dress right and then we
filmed a bit on it and he took my place
that day so you were fine we're filming
the show in Florida the entire time you
were filming you were battling whooping
cough yes you got on the plane from New
York to Florida to film six weeks of a
TV show with whooping cough yes well the
coughs started to decide at like five
four five weeks but my damage on my back
was done I couldn't even move dude they
had to they had to come get me and put
me in like a wheelchair like a jazzy
like a walker I couldn't even move so
anyway I'm in I'm in Tampa okay okay I'm
doing a show in Tampa or was the hot
rock it was uh maybe it was like with
the guys or just you with the guys Tina
Martinez comes to see us right player so
so we are in the back and we're about to
walk out there and I'm already
if I turn wrong once I'm done so I'm
already walking slowly I'm not talking
to anyone I'm talking slowly I look like
I'm a 90 year old man that's how I'm
treating myself
before the show Tino's in the back with
us you know and I go to say and I'm like
oh my God Tino and he comes up to me and
he goes out
he he doesn't know obviously he grabs me
and slaps a big huge hug pulls me in and
goes
and just slaps my back like and like
squeezes me like to say like I just hit
a home run I literally I literally in
his arms I went limp I went oh I slid
through his arms and hit the ground and
he fell onto the floor slid through I
yelped and my I just literally melted
through his arms and hit the ground I
turned purple I was like crying
he thought I was [__] with him he
starts laughing and everyone's like no
I'm like no and he goes oh my God no no
he's he's really hurting tool look at my
muscle in his back and he's like oh my
God I'm so sorry and I I couldn't move
they had to call an emergency
chiropractor chiropractor came they laid
me out they tried to like Snap me and do
something made it [__] worse I walked
on stage I had to have a lit I they put
a lazy boy on the stage and I sat in a
lazy boy for the whole show like I did a
show to 5 000 plus people whatever it
may be in the Lazy Boy the whole show I
didn't go and I was in pain I was like
you know when you're in you know when
your muscle back pain muscle man you
sweat because it's like you're you're so
tensed yeah the whole show I was sitting
in the chair like this just pouring
sweat you think if it was just you you
could have even done it I would have
done I would have done I would have sat
on the seat you know but Sal vulcano uh
unisex t-shirt uh
huh I don't make any money on that
nothing look at that Christian Stefano
autographed Chrissy chaos thing poster
with the homeless pimp 100 bucks that
means somebody got it from a show and
it's just immediately selling it oh yeah
those people follow me in the airports
yeah and by the way we've never signed
that's fake out them what's she doing
with her lips
enough is enough no also she looks like
she's wearing wax lips like that doesn't
look good I will tell you that you know
what I noticed in Miami for the first
time ever when I've been in Miami
everybody got the mass s implants now no
no the lowest amount of plastic surgery
I've ever seen unless the girls are just
getting it to where it looks so real but
even Jasmine commented we think a lot of
people now are going away they're going
towards more towards natural beauty and
the fake now you see somebody with big
lips and big boobs it's more of a turn
off than a turn on where it used to be a
turn on but now you're more like I'd
rather be real I thought it would be the
maybe public convention and opinion but
I thought it's the other way around
everything is just jutting out
everywhere now lips titties ass you name
it
beans greens Tomatoes potatoes lips
titties ask your name it should be the
name of this app lips titties ass you
name it lip cities ask you name it
um yeah so oh they said it is getting
hot it's still are we saying plastic
surgery is getting uh what is a butt
implant is it is it is it what is it I
think a butt implant is a silicone or
something so just like the titty it's
just like a titty just makes your butt
Fuller and higher it's fat it's fat a
Brazilian butt lift involves three basic
steps fat is removed from the hips lower
back thighs abdomen or other areas with
liposuction the extracted fat is
purified and prepared for transfer the
cosmetic surgeon injects fat into
specific points on the buttocks to
increase volume and improve shape would
you get a butt implant for the show
nah
that's too much that's too far right
because then you have a big fat ass for
the rest of your life unless you undo it
it would which is risky
everybody in every every girl now in
Hollywood every Star every freaking name
that's all right that's all most of it's
bought most of it most people are fake
butts all the Kardashians got theirs
removed no kind of over it oh they got
it removed there's no way
because it would be it would be alarming
if they got it removed because it was so
big yo look at the before and afters
no
if you look at them in the in the early
days none of them had anything no yeah
no that's what a couple of billion will
do for you that's what it is a coupleish
million yeah I mean uh but whatever
it's what they I mean on the one hand on
the one hand I'm like okay yeah they all
got plastic surgery and then it made an
army of women do this but on the other
hand I'm like you know you gotta you
gotta be in control of your kids you
know don't let them watch the show it's
it's really nobody's fault but your own
always I mean that's insane that's
insane look at that I know I know which
to me to me it's just not even uh I'm
I'm I'm more into I'd rather just I want
to see natural straight natural beauty
and I wasn't always that way though I
will say something in the Zeitgeist or
it's changed me I wasn't I was I used to
be but now I'm like I'd rather you just
be your natural stuff if you're if
you're going unnatural and you're doing
some type of elective surgery it just
tells me that there's at least at least
at the very least a hint of insecurity
in you which just repels me now a little
bit it makes me scared of you wow the
power of insecurity repels you repels me
I I I I will say this with the face
no one ever looks better unless there's
unless the people that got it done get
it done that's so good that we don't
can't tell but usually you'd know when
someone's had it and it doesn't look
better what happens is too with the face
is there's really only a couple of ways
to alter it so it just everybody starts
to look the same there's nobody who
looks unique anymore right because they
all look like Bratz dolls once you get
the cheek fillers and the lip fillers
what you're doing is everybody looks the
same yeah and God Jesus made us all to
look as unique is different yes he did
yeah now lalit Patel now let's talk
about this if you wanted to get plastic
surgery or she or they I would
understand because they have a condition
called hypertrichosis also known as
werewolf syndrome only around 50 people
in history have ever had it and he has
it where he just grows hair 50 people in
history history yeah
what history history wild there's eight
billion now but that's not including all
the people how many people [__] have we
had on Earth of trillions babe Babble
yeah the language learning app I'm going
to Sicily I'm using Babel if it is
amazing that's that's where you guys you
can take it with you and you can
actually like feel like you're ingrained
in the cultural they literally what they
do is it's it's almost like they teach
you the word and then they kind of quiz
you on it yeah and it's it literally you
start to form words used to I'm thinking
in Italian
whoa you must have been using battle
Yeah ciao in all serious it's 14
languages a language learning app it
makes bite-sized lessons makes learning
fun and you could really want to be
learning less uh a new language because
you're going on a vacation somewhere
because you want to communicate with a
friend or relative whatever because yeah
for whatever reason 14 different
languages and it was created by 150
language experts no AI none of that
stuff this is real people with using the
speech recognition technology which
helps improve your pronunciation and
accent it's not just out of the beach
it's not just uh it's not just the
lessons right they have podcast games
video stories they even have live
classes live classes chess
permanentarity plus a 20-day money-back
guarantee start it right now all you got
to do is go to Babel that's
b-a-b-b-e-l-.com hey babe and you're
gonna get 55 off your subscription when
you go to babble.com hey babe sign up
for 55 off your subscription go to do it
don't do it online because I did it
online and then I got the app so you get
the service in it was just a little bit
easier for me so go to the actual search
engine put in babel.com hey babe you can
see that discount come up and it's great
and it's language learning for Life
Bible language for life
do you do you know do we know that's
that does anyone take us like a since
the census started how many people we've
had how many people turn over including
turnover
discoveries now suggest uh 200 000 BCE
okay
117 billion members of our species have
been born on Earth wow 117 billion
members and he's and there's been less
than 50 cases of the werewolf syndrome
yep and he's got it and not for nothing
but he's he's
walking around like that because he took
a selfie I think you lean into it like
we shouldn't even know unless he wants
to yeah but you can't lean that's
somebody can you play it as much as I
would want to be able to just look past
that I don't
okay is that real no that's it's a real
condition
many of them work as promoted as having
distinct human animal is there no Googs
is it no valves
oh my God that's rough what do you got
to do then shave it every day I don't I
don't think it matters I think you would
have to shave I think it'll grow so fast
probably no surgery for it because
who's going to concentrate all that
money when it's that rare yeah who's
going to do the research for it
huh
you think you can do laser and he just
opted not to
I mean that's that's where I could see a
GoFundMe right that's where I could see
it not like yeah I want to go you know
right people that's a GoFundMe right
like hey I'm a werewolf I need a couple
of million this girl who hasn't become a
boy again her smile is funny that can't
they picked a bad smile pic where she
just looks like she just farted and yeah
eyes yeah it's not good they shouldn't
use this photo she's like mugging yeah
yeah oh that's that's horrible that is
not good
I mean what what is your life like you
know I mean it's I I want to I would
expect a difference it's not easy it's
not like Teen Wolf a butt lift is not
going to make a difference
banging the girl and when shooting the
winning shot no I would say no yeah
but
all right well I mean what can you do
I don't think they could do anything
they that's a rare condition that I
wouldn't want that I wouldn't want that
what about this one then we got Ella
Harper AKA camel girl
she was born with a rare condition that
caused her knees to bend backwards like
Shane McMahon because of this condition
she had to walk on all fours earning her
the nickname camel girl though it was
difficult At first she made a fortune
out of it she earned a weekly wage of
200 in 1886. that's a whole box what's
that now just for inflation
two hundred dollars now from 1886. I'm
gonna guess if 200 a week now in eight
that would be that would be three
thousand dollars a week you think
today's money fight to guess
oh six thousand sixty five hundred a
week that's real money wow wow now hold
on a second let's see what she was
making a year
386 300 and
three three hundred and eighty thousand
three three and three forty just about
340. so she was wow that's you know how
much
back then how much 200 a week would get
you my grandfather went to the movies
for a nickel that was in the like mid
1900s you could buy a house back then
for 200 flat you make it in one week you
buy the house out right yeah no longer
she's just probably trotting around the
house yeah uh Is that real is this real
because that looks like that picture
looks pretty like iPhone and there are a
lot of sick [__] out there that look at
this and they're probably going to
masturbate to that photo because she
looks bent over let's hope not oh that's
insane oh so that's sad that is sad but
it would be nice to say you had sex with
Cameron girl
if we're just being honest if we're just
being open and honest I wonder if she
had any question I want to ask you a
question for the night you have to have
and you have to have sex with one of
them you're going for chemical girl or
werewolf face you have to have sex with
one of them they're both they're both
women I'm gonna do camel girl okay yeah
okay fair enough pimp I'm gonna do her
I'm gonna I'm gonna choose her I'm gonna
choose I do a threesome nice with camel
girl and and werewolf boy yeah why the
hell not get a little bit of it all
exactly I like that I like that and yeah
I like that I'd have snooper effort what
about you who are you taking I go with I
I'd say I'd go with camel girl she's a
pretty girl pretty girl I go with camel
girl
um but I would say that I I take
werewolf boy maybe I I try to I try to
have an intimate night with werewolf uh
boy you really want to do a little camel
Style
laughs doing a camel style is you know
you know what they say when you when you
sleep with her all it takes is one hump
spin hey babe
no right
40.
I I would you do this babe oh wait
before we go I need to ask you please go
to Australia yeah I want to be honest
with you I want to be honest with you
let me be honest with you I have shows
right now on sale in Sydney we are
adding or we've added Melbourne and
Brisbane and I believe New Zealand and
Perth and I'm excited about it but I got
to be on just be honest with you there's
a part of me that doesn't want to go I'm
very scared and about the loneliness
about being on the other side of the
world from my family it's not the flight
it's not that I can deal with that even
though I know it'll get difficult it's
the distance itself on the other side of
the world of my family I just don't know
if I have it in me I don't know even
though the shows are selling and I
appreciate it I don't and it's nothing
that's the good people of Australia I
just don't know if I can handle it what
do you think what is this slated for uh
June which is June 9th is Sydney and
then the other shows are after that and
you're going who who's going with you
I'm gonna bring Sergio chicon okay so
it's just you two just us too literally
just YouTube no one else is going no
nobody's going and you're gonna okay
because it's too much to bring my family
how long is the whole trip so right now
I believe we'd leave June 6th to get
there on the 7th have a day to
recuperate on the eighth and then do the
show The Ninth and then leave New
Zealand I believe June 15th are you
doing New Zealand too in Boston New
Zealand yeah Oh supposedly gorgeous I
wanted to go there and so okay so so
until when so I believe it's we're gonna
leave I would leave New York and my
family June 6th and come back like June
16th so be gone for 10 days have you
done 10 days in a location that was more
accessible and been able to handle it
I've done 10 days 14 days in La I've
done but it was brutal but well it's
that's brutal because it's like even
that three hour difference is like you
know you can't talk to them at certain
so now it's like when I'm awake they'll
be asleep when they're asleep I'll be
awake so I won't it'll be 10 days of
like probably barely talking there's no
bringing them it's too expensive I can't
do it at all yeah so I don't know what
to do should I my question is do I do I
just preemptively make an excuse to
cancel now or what do I do what do I
just go for it now just go do the shows
what kind of shows are they the money is
good moderate it's good but I could make
you know with the inflate with the
adjustment for the Australian currency
with by the time you pay everybody out
and all that stuff I could make that
same amount in a weekend here in in the
in the United States what is it it's for
the experience well the experience if
you're but are you going you're not
really what experience to say jokes in
front of people that are from Australia
or to see Australia I guess to see
Australia but then are you going to see
Australia or do you have to go from one
city to the next city to the next city
just like here like are you gonna have
down time where you're actually enjoying
Melbourne and all that stuff I think
like two days of it
I don't know I I I was asked to go to
Australia multiple times even for the
show I I would not go to Australia
unless I had unless I had minimum two
weeks of looking around if I went when I
went I went for three weeks right it's
just how Are You Gonna Fly a day each
way you have to and by the way you have
to fly to Melbourne you know Melbourne
to Sydney is what six hours like it's
not it's like flying from New York to
L.A so the days when you have to travel
all this thing are travel days where
you're flying the whole time dude I took
off on uh November 5th I landed November
7th right my birthday was November 6th I
didn't have it that's insane it's crazy
right also my seat was broken what do
you mean it was the only seat on the
plane that was broken there was and this
plane was full what was wrong with the
first class ticket too the [__]
that's big Marshall pad the seat pad it
just caved in so it was like resting on
like the like the the rods underneath it
was just completely broken caved in so
it was a very uncomfortable when they
sent a guy up there who was wearing an
orange vest like a like one of the guys
he was like the maintenance guy and he
came he looked at he's like
yeah I'm not able to do anything with
that yeah so I was like well what am I
supposed to do and he's like well the
flight was full so he's like you can go
the next the next fight was the next day
there's only one a day you were in
Australia or in New York in New York
going to Australia okay and uh they were
like you can get off or you can stay and
we'll just give you your ticket no they
didn't give me jack [__] they brought me
a blanket and they put it underneath the
seat and I sat on a broken seat with a
blanket underneath and then they brought
me a cheap bottle of champagne as an
apology
and I was on that thing for like 19
hours sitting on a broken seat straight
direct flight direct flight and it was
not cheap was it was the food good at
least on the Fly I don't recall so well
let me ask you this 19 hours on a flight
I understand your your seat was broken I
get that so that takes away let's say it
wasn't
I've heard that the first class
experience on a Australian Airline is
different than any first class
experience that you get on domestic oh
actually I had business so there's I
think this first business and then even
even coach is like different because
they can't ask people to do that right
so what's business like okay it was
still it was like Jet Blue Mint yeah
like you're in a pond and stuff yeah lay
flat seats right but but even after
three hours you're like get me off this
plane like I will tell you I thought it
was going to be worse than it was I
really did because at a certain point
you're not thinking about time you just
get on you're like I live here now
and you do all the things you like eat a
meal watch a movie go to sleep eat a
meal watch a movie go to sleep you know
what I mean so people are people ha by
the way people have to take multiple
shits there's there's at least 10 ships
dropped on an Australian to New York on
Australia flight 10 shits bro my plane
was
two seats
four seats two fourth two or two four
five
in the middle that big with a second
floor I never I always saw them in the
movies I never saw a plane with a real
section second floor was the first class
woke up no no just another another I
don't know what was up there no because
we were first class down here there was
a lounge
you can go get a drink there was a bar
like a bartender there was a a flight
attendant at like a service bar
but it was a lounge you could go sit in
seats over there
so so when there were steps to go
upstairs it was wild so if you so the
shit's what I'm saying so many shits
what airline
but so yeah I always thought about that
there have to be on that flight people
are [__] you have to [__] it's a day
long and there's like 500 people on it
so how many shits do you think are on
Australia to New York flight if you had
to guess one one way one way I think
there's 50 shits that happen
cumulatively total 50 shifts let's just
say this 400 let's just say the plane
that's 400 people I don't know what it
has 50 shits means 50 people yes 50
people out of uh 400 sitting at least
once in one day right is like what 12
something like that 12 of the people did
12 of the people take a [__] I would say
yes wow
is the bathroom any bigger on an
Australian Airline than it is you know
in our can I don't recall that I don't
recall but do you think that I should go
or don't go not that you're telling me
what to do just what your advice take me
through how I would feel you knowing me
so I loved Australia I loved it
um but it is like the the Melbourne
picture like Brooklyn okay Sydney like
Manhattan and then Brisbane I didn't go
to uh but there's some beautiful beaches
down there and I I went to like I went
to like the reef and I went to the
desert so you're not going to do that I
would not go if you are not if you don't
have time to experience the places
you're going to right because what are
you doing then what really are you doing
you're flying for 40 hours minimum just
to get back and forth not including
there
to then go to tell a joke just like we
do hear the grind you're doing the grind
over there right if it's not and if it's
not at a premium amount of money why
would you put yourself through that and
I don't mean to take away like everyone
in Australia hates me now from keeping
you from them but it's my honest opinion
I would I would have made it a thing
that's what friends are for yeah like if
I was going with the kids and Jazz and
the kids no I would go for a month I
would go do your thing like go do the
thing and then stay you know I mean
because your shows are probably every
night or every two nights right so you
can't you can't you can't simmer I would
I would go do all your shows and then be
like all right now I'm staying another
two three weeks here now yeah because
the thing is I already have like 75
percent of the room sold out in Sydney
so it would be a lot of tickets to like
but it's it's we haven't put anything
else on sale yet just Sydney so I'll
tell you this Sydney and Melbourne
you're not gonna it's beautiful like
it's on the water you're gonna see all
the you know you're gonna see the opera
house yeah I stay right there but at the
end of the day it's it's you know it's a
city but it's a cool
Metropolitan City like this you know
you're gonna have great restaurants
you're gonna have great bars you're
gonna have great Parks you're gonna have
great art and culture right you get that
here so if you're not going to go there
and really dig into that then you're not
going to really be thrilled with Sydney
and Melbourne I was there for a long
time and I like really went to all those
things but then I also went to the
freaking reef and the desert so it's a
total another experience so I came away
from not being like that's I never
stayed in the desert I never went to the
reef so if you're just going to the
cities
what are you really going to get out of
it pimp and vanitya what should I do
I agree I've been to Australia before
and I did all that and I was there for
six weeks so you when you go you go but
also it is the time of year where it's
not warm you love Colder Weather so do
you go for the weather and the season no
because actually now it's my whole
mindset on cold weather has changed now
because I've lost some weight now I'm
looking for the warm weather I like the
warm weather I don't want to be enrolled
I want to be in the world you want to
take your robot yeah look at me I'm half
naked on the show right now and and so
I've so that kelly green
I think so I like it yeah Amazon's
vibrant Amazon I think yeah Shot in the
Dark no my my Google the Italian woman
my manager Emilio was wearing it and
then I was like that's okay
he was wearing that outfit in white it
looked great with his Miami fit and I
said that's the craziest thing I've ever
seen he goes I'm sending one to your
house but I'm sorry you go on Amazon and
be like you like you like green shorts
and shirt what do you type into Amazon
that comes up let me tell you right now
I'll tell you because you sent me the
link oh the Italian woman I'm gonna have
to cancel do you shop clothes on Amazon
you do Pim should I go or don't go
what's your thoughts
they sold the tickets but I know how
much you hate being away from your
family so it kind of seems like a bust
to me it seems like it's not going to be
worth it you should probably figure it
out and have your family go with you so
you can enjoy it yeah but they can't
come they'll be in school so they can
come and I can't take it drop out what's
the point but I can't take Violet I
can't take Violet who's not even won't
even be two yet on a 20-hour plane ride
maybe you just push it until Violet can
come
if you are getting money you can't turn
down maybe you say 10 days you make it
so you make sure you're on the phone to
face time with them on a small crossover
right you got to be up uh it's 12 hours
is the difference I think yeah right so
you gotta is it is it 16 hours is the
difference
yeah when it's the morning here it's the
night it's not even the night like what
time is it right there right now in
Sydney Australia
it's it's what time is it here it is 1
42 p.m here
it's seven
yeah so I could it would be nine o'clock
right 9 pm is when you talk to me for
this I've been going back and forth so
much about this about do I do it or do I
it's like been like all I think about
your travels booked none of it's booked
yet only Sydney is on sale are you
worried about a repeat Puerto Rico thing
what you did in Puerto Rico you booked
the show sold it out and then canceled
but but I canceled it because I was with
my family and I didn't want to leave
them so I wouldn't do that there but my
thought is I again I love the people of
Australia and I know they listen to our
products nothing but support for them
but I'm just asking you to put yourself
in my shoes who already feels burnt out
by the road and my skin feels burned
from Miami but I feel burnt out mentally
that I'm like now to go away for all
that time you know I'm gonna take July
and August off I think from the road but
I'm like those 10 12 days in Australia
are it's all I think about like I was in
Florida for five days and I was like I
want to [__] go home I don't care how
much money you know the answer you know
how you feel already I'm just
reinforcing what you really feel but the
answer is go when the kids are a bit
older and put this store on sale and
bring the entire family that's the
answer that's that's a Move in half yeah
you know maybe they you probably want to
travel with them but maybe I don't know
if you're going to want to bring them
everywhere maybe they just post up in
the city you do your little Run come
back in like five days because I have
two shows that I'm booking in Christmas
time and one in Berlin one in Munich in
Germany because I always want to do your
dreams my dream but Jazz and the kids
are coming with me I don't even think
twice about it I'm like I can't wait to
go right I don't care if I lose money I
don't care just pay for the kids flight
right but this I'm like
when can you cancel how how long do you
have to that's why I wanted to bring it
up because I wanted to know if we could
kind of game plan an excuse okay okay
well
this is
[Music]